hey youtubers it's Charlie so we got to
talk about some arrow WTF this is gonna
be my episode 11 video just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen it yet so
here we go there is a new round of the
reverse flash spring if you didn't see
my flash video it's gonna stay open
until I post my legends of tomorrow
video tomorrow all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video
same time to giveaway that happens every
week so just like the flash very WTF
episode this week of arrow but for very
different reasons that you know big
thumbs up big thumbs down I think a lot
of you will be really happy with the
shadowspire twist when I explain it it's
a big Easter Egg for Deathstroke in the
comics in the big thumbs down for Amanda
Waller that's gonna require some serious
DC extended universe movie splaining so
just starting with top 5 WTF number 5
shadowspire from the comics explained in
the episode there's a character named
Joyner who is part of an organization
called shadowspire that Andy gets
wrapped up in and in the flashbacks we
find out in present day that that same
organization is trying to take Rubicon
from Argus and Amanda Waller the Joyner
character is named after one of the
creators of shadowspire in the comics
Tom Joyner he was a writer on the
Deathstroke comic book and that's where
the organization appeared for the first
time Deathstroke ended up investigating
this criminal organization and it turned
out to be shadowspire on the number 4
WTF surprise surprise Baron writer from
the flashbacks is the leader of
shadowspire which is also true in the
comics Baron blitzkrieg is one of the
leaders of shadowspire in the comics so
now we have one more big reason that you
could bring Deathstroke back for a big
shadowspire arc in the future obviously
Deathstroke has a real big connection
with hive 2 so there are multiple ways
you could bring him back but now we know
their drug operation is fueled through
Lian Yu
which was awesome the locals call it
purgatory my guess is is this Diggle and
II flashback scene teeing up shadowspire
is happening sometime when Oliver was in
Hong Kong before he was taken back to
the island so Oliver flashback timeline
refresher Oliver capsizes on the Queens
gambit lands on the island eventually
makes it off is in Hong Kong Baron
Reiter then comes to the island and then
Oliver is taken back by Amanda Waller so
given that all
in present day makes no reference to
knowing about shadowspire I'm assuming
that he doesn't learn about that in the
flashbacks even though he will be facing
Baron Reiter Baron Reiter is the big
boss of the flashbacks the big boss of
present-day gotta be damian darhk-- from
what marc guggenheim has said I'm not
expecting Baron rider to show up in
present day but I don't know exactly
what their plans are for crossing over
the flashbacks with present day this
season it sounds like they weren't doing
that this season like the fact that
Constantine showed up in the flashbacks
and showed up in present day is like is
that the closest you'll get the same
flashbacks overlap with present day but
number 3 WTF Felicity starts
hallucinating herself high on drugs yay
everybody have a good time
it's goth Felicity from her past it's
really just her subconscious trying to
make her doubt herself doubt her place
and team arrow but surprisingly within
the same episode she comes to her senses
and it has a big call to action that
doesn't mean that her struggle is over
like she's still gonna struggle being in
the wheelchair but she has mr. terrific
driving her all over town and the new
layer is wheelchair accessible so she's
all hands on deck and she has a new
codename overwatch
I was gonna use Oracle but that was
already taken boom shots fired
he was so awesome that they followed up
to that with her showing Oliver the
picture that this is what I used to look
like questionable fashion choices
the old me would a totally stolen
Rubicon made made some sort of political
statement well the old me would have
snapped your neck very big thumbs up for
excellent use of Laurel in this episode
Laurel training montage with Oliver that
then turns into a joke in and of itself
about their relationship Oliver casually
dropping the barrack and time travel her
referencing their relationship which
they have not done in a while I am
curious like if arrow goes seven seasons
if they will ever get to the point where
you have the Black Canary green arrow
relationship when they come together and
not necessarily get married but when
they come together for the first time as
superheroes when they're both
superheroes that is something that we
will have to circle back around in a
couple of seasons for I'm not expecting
any Black Canary green arrow shipping
anytime soon number two WTF Diggle sets
his brother free despite the fact that
he is a pathological liar
they keeps having those flashbacks with
Andi and Diggle them having those really
nice brotherly moments in Afghanistan
andis
starts lying to Diggle then later he
kind of explains his thought process I
cut ties with those dudes when I left
the military but he's so cynical that
he's like I just I wanted to make sure
that I was taken care of so starting
right around here when Andy is talking
to Diggle he just flat-out lies and then
then we get the reveal of Baron Reiter a
little something extra for your loyalty
but the way they left things at the end
of the episode with Diggle taking Andy
in felt really hopeful so I'm wondering
if that she's gonna come back to bite
Diggle in the ass it was a pretty tender
family moment kind of matching the
Oliver Felicity moment that they had at
the end take it for what you will but a
pathological liar is a pathological liar
but finally number one WTF Amanda Waller
gets shot in the head you just do not
come back from that so there are a
couple things that could be going on
here like as you're all like screaming
and shaking your fists and flipping your
desks over one they could have killed
her character permanently on the TV show
because she's being used in the movies
and Warner Brothers doesn't want there
to be confusion between TVs and movies
it could be a situation where the arrow
producers were told that they could not
use the Amanda Waller character anymore
no confirmation on that option two is is
that the arrow producers preemptively
did that and they're slowly moving away
from the Amanda Waller in Suicide Squad
characters that are going to be done in
the movies so that they don't run into a
situation like that but as a lot of you
will remember there is a king shark
Diggle crossover happening on the flash
in a couple weeks so Diggle is going to
be tracking down King shark for Suicide
Squad purposes so I don't know if
they're gonna have Argus in that episode
have they're gonna explain it but Argus
still exists I'm assuming that Lyla is
gonna fill the void because they made
her sound like the next best person to
Amanda Waller like most highly trusted
agent knows all of our secrets so it
makes sense that Lyla would step up but
if you saw the teaser for the next
episode the big news is that Roy is
coming back next week it's gonna be the
calculator episode that character has
already been confirmed to be Felicity's
father so we're gonna have a lot of fun
in the calculator is a big birds-of-prey
villain so be looking for birds of prey
Easter eggs here's my big question for
you guys though why do you think they
killed Amanda Waller and do you think
that they'll ever bring her back in a
flashback or they'll have some crazy
explanation some comic book explanations
where it's like Amanda Waller
has a life model decoy or a twin you
know some crazy comic-book explanation
for how someone didn't die but my
thought is just given the way it was
presented in this episode she is dead
not coming back in the lazarus pit is
not an option remember earlier this
season Nyssa corrupted the Lazarus Pit
they can't use it anymore that there's
no more lazarus pit to be had I know a
lot of you guys have been asking Suicide
Squad questions that the next big big
trailer will probably come when Batman V
Superman is released and because they
just released that trailer with the
Queen song it might be a smaller version
of that I don't know they'll probably do
something they're not gonna let Batman V
Superman swing through without letting
Suicide Squad tag along a little bit if
you guys spotted any other Easter eggs
in the episode just write them below in
the comments
aside from your big belly burger
shadowspire Baron writer Tom Joyner the
writer from the comics - joiner the
character as well as I'm taking a huge
shot at the Barbara Gordon Oracle just a
lot of fun I really do hope Felicity
keeps taking all those drugs just in
case you guys haven't seen it I posted
my flash video last night probably one
of the best episodes of the flash all
season long you can click here to watch
that in you can click here for the agent
Carter video I just posted thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight